luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys and welcome back to the
lehigh pen show powered by icon plus capital the
vc firm so joining me today is a really exciting
guest it is sean culkin the nfl tight end who
said that he is going to turn his entire salary
into bitcoin sean welcome to the show how are you
hey thanks so much for having me i'm doing
great good to be here yeah it's really good
to have you um before we jump in i do just want
to say a quick thank you to all my sponsors
because if it wasn't for them this wouldn't be
possible um so this is um sponsored by block fi
you can actually get amazing interest rates on
your crypto your stable coins whatever it is and
there is a description for you somewhere and this
month it's actually um sponsored by coin um by
compass mining sorry so compass mining are really
interesting they're actually the company that
makes bitcoin mining accessible for everyone you
just buy your machine pick a hosting facility and
let them do the work so if you do want to start
mining some bitcoin then head to compassmining.io
it's really cool because mining bitcoin right now
is pretty impossible so there you go so thank you
to them so sean welcome to the show i've been so
excited to speak to you the first thing actually i
wanted to ask you is can you explain to me what a
tight end is because i'm english and like i don't
know any of this stuff yeah sure sure so uh let's
start with uh offense and defense so tight ends
on offense and it's kind of a combination
of a receiver who has to catch the ball
and an offensive lineman who is like bigger guys
that are blocking protecting the quarterback or
creating holes for the running back so a tight
end is somebody that pretty much has to do both
so they're pretty um very multi-dimensional
have to know the run game the pass game
i like to think they're the smartest guys on the
field the most versatile but it's fun because
yeah you got to be fast but then you have
to be strong yeah i feel like that kind of
represents what i know of you so far you seem to
be quite diverse i know that you have a finance
background which we'll get into but um before we
do i'd love to know a little bit more about you
personally um your background where you come
from um i'd love to hear it all yeah yeah so
i'm from indian rocks beach florida it's about 30
minutes south from tampa and i was born and raised
there my whole life i have one brother who pretty
much i pretty much tried to do everything he
did growing up he ran track played football and
basketball those are the three sports i did and
just over time i initially was a basketball
prospect i kind of thought that was my path
uh to collegiate sports and my senior year i
decided to play football in college because i
kind of just had more of the mentality to get
bigger and stronger and i also in six five and
basketball nowadays you have to be like six eight
did you say you're six five yeah six five six five
damn that's insane but that's awesome but that's
so short for basketball yeah i know yeah i was the
shortest guy on my team my uh i was on adidas
team for florida and i was one of the shortest
guys and i kind of saw the writing on the wall and
um just all more of a you know more of a upside
in football so i went to university of missouri
and that was the first year they were in the sec
and that was a really cool experience and from
there just uh yeah kind of like as you said i i
started studying finance i realized that football
could end at any point in time i tore my mcl
and luckily it wasn't anything serious but
i knew that injuries do occur in the sport
and i don't want to look back and reflect on
my time in college getting a free education
and not take advantage of that so i switched to
finance and just fell in love with it immediately
it was the first time where i had a passion
equivalent to my interest in football and just
immersed myself in the readings and understanding
the lectures and kind of was using football to
uh almost set up a career after football like
and i know at one time i wanted to do wall street
so i was yeah yeah so i was you know i was uh an
equity research analyst for an insurance firm and
sitting on bloomberg crunching excel spreadsheet
numbers and um handling the endowment money for
the business school and just and studying for the
cfa level one so i'm going like 80 90 hours a week
yeah on top of being a d1 athlete and figured
you know whenever football ends i'm already
ready for that and through just over time i
slowly just navigated more and more to bitcoin
i think that is um i think that's really
important you mentioned having a backup plan
but i i see it's not so much a backup plan because
i think backup plans have really bad connotations
it's kind of like i'll have that in case i fail
so it's not i don't mean it like that it's more
like life is so unpredictable and you know there's
so many different things that can happen to you
um not even just you you know just like
circumstances like let's just say covert as an
example so many people's businesses you know just
kind of totally went to rubbish unfortunately um
so you fell in love with finance what about it did
you fall in love with that's really interesting
just uh intricacies and complexity of just
the markets and how they all are intertwined
i thought it was just fascinating how everything
um was linked there's just so much to learn right
and i love the i think it's also important
to note that my dad was a gold bug so i was
already exposed to that contrarian view as well
growing up on the central bank fallacies and
the concept of money and questioning you know fiat
systems and um so between that and then what i was
doing for my internship the um the studies that
i had in college it just there's just so much
material to learn and once i'm um just completely
committed to something i just obsess over it and
i want to try to understand everything so
that was really it just just the amount of
dense information available in the ratings and
obviously you can make money you know through
at one point i even tried to dabble with day
trading and realize that that's yeah that's not
it's a it's too it's too much time um it required
so i just like that stress yes too much stress my
emotions are involved i've never yeah yeah it's
not not worth it so um and then yeah this is good
yeah no i'm just gonna say so like so you
obviously your dad had a gold background
which is really interesting and we'll get to that
but like given that you studied finance did you
feel when you came across bitcoin that suddenly
you had to unlearn everything you had learned
eventually at some point i had to just rethink
through things yes in a way unlearn yes of
course which i think that is important you know
for for success i think you sometimes have to
look back on history and your upbringing
and what was taught and just question and
and think for yourself i think is the most
powerful thing any individual can do so
bitcoin definitely aided in that process of just
going back and questioning things and reading
and understanding and thinking for myself
deciding for myself on what i think is the
best store of value for my wealth and i think
that's um you know at some point in time
any person that's with high conviction in
bitcoin has probably had to go through that path
yeah i think the you make a really interesting
point because that is one of the best things about
bitcoin in that it encourages you to question
what you've already learned and there are so many
narratives that are just shoved down our throats i
mean even inflation is an example i've never seen
so much pro-inflation media recently um right you
know it is and we're just almost told to accept it
you know you just accept what you're told
yeah um and and cpi is the best reflection
of inflation right like like the idea of that i
that was quick for me just in talking to my dad
and just seeing how you know the compute the cpi
it didn't necessarily make sense and then early
on when i started you know listening to sailor and
how he talked about yeah inflation being kind of
linked to the lifestyle that you want right what
are you trying to buy like what kind of life style
are you trying to live and provide for your family
kind of dictates also your inflation bracket in
a way and if you're just sitting at home and you
know staying at your parents and not paying rent
and um you know just watching netflix all day
like inflation's not too bad you know that's the
example that he used but if you're trying to buy
a home and eventually have kids and send them to
university for education and healthcare it's
like well inflation's quite high yeah it is and
it it just we were talking obviously earlier
and now we were talking about my book and
and everything that i have coming out and like
i'm i'm writing about inflation and when i saw
this pro media sorry this media um pro-inflation
um content coming out from the media i was upset
like i was hurt you know i just i'm just there
like talking about how um you know my grandfather
was able to do this and now we have to work
double to be able to even almost do that and yeah
the same day you've got inflation could be good
there's a silver lining because you know salaries
are going up it doesn't work like that it doesn't
work like that and unfortunately i think people
just because of you know their lives people
are busy right and unless you take the time
to allocate learning more you see a headline
and then you just move on with your day and
they already have this conception of okay well
inflation maybe is good i don't know oh wages
are increasing i'm sure that's all true and they
go on and they don't know and understand that
you're demanding more of my time and resources
to consume the same amount of goods and or do the
same and consume less and once people understand
that and just the relationship of time and money
then that's when you kind of just eventually
inevitably right that's what we all say gratitude
towards bitcoin yeah i mean it's all of it though
because like it for me it's just it's not bitcoin
in general it's kind of like this slave mentality
i feel that we're taught um in that um you know
trading time for dollars like that's a big one
and that's something that everybody feels that
they have to do and you actually don't right a
salary right yeah yeah yeah yes it goes back to
rich dad poor dad philosophy i've been yeah seeing
him pop up a lot lately on my just you know the
instagram reels and everything and yeah you know
he talks about just as soon as you take a salary
and unfortunately there's you know people that
where they like to drive or just um direction and
you know and how to provide financially for
themselves or their family in other ways like
you know it's a good way of making a living but
there's it's not the only way and once you start
to stop working for money unless you're your money
worked for you that's the ultimate um solution for
for success yeah and i feel like bitcoin is
wrapped into all of that and we'll get to it
but i was tweeting actually yesterday about how
the nine to five is a scam and i got a lot of
backlash for it right and i don't mean it straight
up i get that obviously some people have a nine to
five everybody's different it's whatever suits but
for me that's not the issue it's that you're just
not in this day and age with inflation you're just
not going to retire in the way that you deserve to
retire by the time you deserve to retire yeah
i think yeah because the 9-5 was accustomed to
gosh you know the fed fund rate being so high
right at some point you could place your money
and fix income and get 15 or to place it in a cd
and get five percent and you know you had only had
to work nine to five for x amount of years and
then you retired and you lived happily and and
unfortunately i don't know if that's the case
like that's what i said early on um and when
i made this decision it's like regardless of your
views on bitcoin like just overall you look at the
current economic environment like what asset class
right now do you trust to provide um a positive
real real yield right so uh for me obviously i
think the asymmetric trade that bitcoin offers is
unparalleled to any other asset and but yeah it's
it's quite sad i mean the stat too also it's you
know if you had a million dollars pre-1971 i think
it was in 1971 now you need like i think it's like
6.5 million dollars to have the same equivalent
purchasing power and that's i mean that's crazy
that's you know over 50 years and you know and
that's just in the u.s if you look at globally
you know people are experiencing inflation rates
that are what are exciting way faster than the u.s
rights are right it's it's it's really sad
honestly and that's i think that's also why
you know this the everyone says bitcoin is hope
that's what we mean it's hope it's sound money
it's available to all it's not just domestic it's
it's a global play yeah absolutely and like just
even outside of finance just with i'm a very
political person so just like with everything
that's going on geopolitically right now i i
find comfort and peace in bitcoin and that it is
opting out of the system but with all of that in
mind that how did you first hear about bitcoin
yeah so kind of funny story i was when i was an
equity research analyst at the time i remember uh
the firm had a subscription to bloomberg magazine
and they would just sit on the desk and i remember
just having a little bit of a break and grabbed
the magazine and i just they started talking about
blockchain satoshi nakamoto this anonymous creator
of this peer-to-peer electronic payment system and
it just i quickly could link it to gold that
was something that i i started to digest
but unfortunately it was i think five days it was
like at the end of my summer internship before
camp started my last year at mizzou and once
that started yeah yeah yeah so once it starts
it's like 5am to 9pm for 30 days and then you
start the regular season so as we all know i
think unless you have skin in the game unless you
put capital into it like you're probably going to
forget forget about it you're not going to be
invested personally emotionally to learn more
and unfortunately i think the price was 750 at
the time but that was my first exposure to it
but never bought it and just over time i think
it's also important to note that i was teammates
with russell [ __ ] with the la chargers for three
years so we would have really good conversations
just in the training room locker room just
in between meetings and i always appreciated
his contrarian view um that a lot of bitcoiners
have right so that was the beginning process
where okay like it just it makes a little bit
more sense at first i kind of couldn't get over
the volatility of it i think as a lot of people
do and because you're kind of thinking oh well
it's supposed to be just a currency and i think
once you start to see there's levels to it where
how about store value let's start soar value there
and then let's see once adoption happens once um
you know the price kind of stabilizes
as it gets appreciates the whole
bitcoinization aspect if that happens like over
time then it's definitely going to be used as a
you know currency i could definitely see that
happening but it's it's it could be okay it's
volatile but then there's how many countries
out there right now that don't even have
opportunity to be banked and have any type
of currency that's not being deflated away
at 15 month over month right so once you started
thinking like that then it just made me want to
really dive in and learn more and just
through time my conviction grew but it really
didn't get to the level of where
it is now until like november 2020
i march 2020 was a big time i started to learn
more about it but i was also just coming off an
achilles surgery um that was so i was pretty much
putting all my time just trying to get healthy
and back to get back on a team and then once i
signed with the ravens i spent last year with them
and once i had a little bit of an injury on
my ankle i was out for a few weeks had some
more time on my hands mid-season and that's
when bitcoin was starting to pop off and just
bought some learned more and then it's been you
know that's that's all she said right it's it's
been i've been completely obsessed since then no
it's good i love it um perfect timing as well but
you mentioned that it reminded you of gold which
is really interesting your dad's a gold bug so so
tell me the train of thought do you think i mean
you didn't go and put a bunch of money into gold
i mean i don't know if you did you put it into
bitcoin it sounds like so how did you weigh up
the difference between bitcoin and gold like what
sold you on bitcoin over gold i'm assuming you're
sold on bitcoin over gold yeah i think if you look
at stock to flow it's superior it's better it's
more transparent this issue is right like what
are the asset class do you just know exactly what
the protocol is going to be like for that the
next 100 years um i liked how like technology
wasn't in the game when for for gold to last
5 000 years right like that's such a big
um you know that's such a long period of time but
short in terms of just the existence of the world
right and when you start to introduce technology
and what the effect of that is and what you see
going on with blockchain utilization and then
now bitcoin and then the layer two and then
younger generations wanting to you know use it
and adopt it yeah question fiat that's becoming
a popular topic right if you just kind of
extrapolate that going forward like what
is the use case for gold like i don't know
many people that are just wow i can't wait
to get a gold necklace like i can't wait to use
gold like i just don't i love gold necklaces
but it just seemed like it was inferior in every
category yeah and other than track record and
this isn't two years three years this is 12
years still short in comparison to gold but
if you see what if you take a step back and just
see um just what's being built the infrastructure
the amount of resources and how it's becoming
political now and you see that trend it's a i
just i see um capital influx definitely leaving
gold and going into bitcoin i mean so like
the gold thing is so interesting to me um because
i'm totally with you when it comes to the use case
like i love a good gold necklace but that's about
it there's not much i can't really hold my wealth
in this little necklace here so totally with
you um but it's interesting because um bitcoin
is so hard to sell to the older generation
um especially um sorry especially over gold
but i feel like um millennials the next
gen z i feel like it's such an obvious sell
um you know when it comes to portability and
so many different things the use cases of it um
it's also fun like i know that might sound
kind of weird but i do find it fun yeah um
you know yeah absolutely it's it's definitely i
think i mean other than uh that that the dynamic
of the shift um you know family it's like what no
one's there there's no gold twitter right that no
you know um it's it's just different i i i think
you're at the front of a revolution right like
you're at the front of a revolution is incredible
um but does your dad get on board with bitcoin
given he's a gold bag it's uh it's
it's it's been easy because of his
you know attractive uh what
he finds attractive in gold
but then there's also that hurdle of him
just being older right he's i think now 71 so
sometimes he just will get it and i think it's so
close and then boom he'll like have this question
but he's starting to understand it um he's
definitely wait what's his question like where
does he get stuck on uh usually energy uh okay
and then just i think just the volatility in a
way when you look at on a short-term perspective
how does that equate to a store of value but then
i think it just takes it takes a lot of research
and conviction to zoom out and just not be
stomach by volatility in the short term any way
possible right like i think if you just look at it
a lot of people unfortunately they're so
emotionally involved when it comes to money
so when it's going like this it's you know some
people don't have unique conviction i think to
just be okay with that and it takes time and
he i don't he hasn't put the time other than
a couple articles he's probably researched on
his own and the conversations that we've had
but he needs more but he's definitely coming
around he'll be orange killed before 2022
for sure oh i love that that's cool no i totally
understand um my dad has been a finance for years
um he's not like a gold bug but he's in finance
so he gets the situation um and when tesla put um
their 1.5 or 1.6 i can't remember billion um into
bitcoin i told my dad and his first response was
okay you're gonna sell now i'm like
no now is when we hold really hard
i was like no this is when we hold really tight i
was like if we're getting money from these kind of
people then you know it's it's incredible but you
make a point it is becoming so political um and
a lot of people say that it's a political for a
million reasons i think it is political but that's
another debate for another time but it's really
interesting what's happening with el salvador um
there's so much hostility um from so many
different places countries governments
organizations institutions um i think it's so sad
because like the country is just trying to make a
better life for everyone by trying something
new yeah no exactly i think it's unfortunate
that i think they could link you know maybe it's
um crime rate and just previous you know history
when it comes to el salvador and just extrapolate
that to like what the situation at hand is now
and like you don't know that right like it's like
i'm glad that peter mccormack could sit down with
him and understand and have a conversation
because they're just trying to do the right
thing and provide hope to the people and it's
unfortunate that some people can't wrap their
minds around that um but to your point like
i think it definitely will become political
it's starting to happen now and i think that
will continue for um the you know foreseeable
future but at some point i do think it transcends
politics like from my um experience i've never
been in a room where i could sit down with like a
hard right conservative in the very left liberal
and usually you're never going to come and see eye
to eye right like you're always going to either
not say what you really want to say or it's going
to go to a you know really elevated argument and
i've been in the rooms where i've introduced
bitcoin and the concept of it and it is pretty
remarkable how there's some common ground there i
i think like i guess where the light you know the
light kind of clicked for me where it's like okay
this is something that i think transcends politics
like maybe i socially it's like i see um you know
what maybe uh democrats and liberals would want
to introduce and i'm like man i i definitely
see the reform and need for that because it's
sadness um you know there's situations like that
but then let's talk about the solution right
like is it expanding the money supply at even
a higher rate is that what's better for those
marginalized groups where the more position
the more wealth that you have stored in cash
like the more honestly you need
bitcoin and it's hard right now because
unfortunately this is the way life works
sometimes you know those um individuals don't have
disposable income to this put in bitcoin that can
they don't need it for the long term right they
might need it in the short term and the volatility
is something that needs to be explained to them
and they need to do their own research but i
would like to think that if they don't need it
at least for you know obviously i would like to
think 10 plus years for long term investment but
at least like a four or five year you know cycle i
truly believe bitcoin is it's it's it's it's hope
you know even more for those people
that get benefit from the appreciation
and the fact it's not going to be deflated away
yeah i think it is something which can definitely
bring both sides together but i only feel that
way to an extent um because i don't know where
you form the political spectrum but my um my
audience know where i fall i'm very much like i
i'd be a republican if i was american basically
i'd really enjoy texas let's just believe it
but um but i just i just sort of feel
that a a sort of left wing or a democratic
mentality would be to have more control less
freedom um you know more government intervention
more regulation just more involvement i just feel
like bitcoin is just like from a philosophical
from a philosophical standpoint really anti that
you know it is yeah no you bring up a good point
because you know i kind of i'm just talking
about just you know monetary policy and the
issues at hand and what is the right solution
but yes to your other point i definitely think
you know when you talk about um the left side
of it the democrats like they definitely um
it's kind of yeah the more control they have the
better in a way right so that's and that's where
bitcoin differs because bitcoin stands for freedom
right self-sovereignty taking responsibility for
you know where you like just store your wealth
the keys component of it how are you what are
you using for custody like there's responsibility
in that but that's the beauty of it as well and
it's yeah i i i could definitely see how that's
gonna be some hurdle to get over um politically so
so you put your so did you end up actually
putting your entire salary into bitcoin is
that what happened yeah so the the crazy story
on that is uh two or three weeks after that i
end up getting released so um right now what does
that mean you ended up getting released release
meaning i got um cut from the chiefs at the time
so you're gonna have to give more i know so um
remember i'm not american um so usually there's
so there's 90 guys on a roster initially in the
off season right and then you'll work to 53.
usually that that they cut down from 90 to 53
from august and camp which has always been
the case um for me i've actually never been
released or cut is the terms that we use and
three weeks after that decision i end up getting
cut or released so i wasn't on the team of the
chiefs so when it comes to salary it's um i mean
i was getting paid already at the time the the the
the checks in the offseason uh no i was getting a
bitcoin at the time so i already said you were
getting paid in bitcoin yeah i was getting paid
in bitcoin but not just the complete salary that
i would have during the season so that's you know
it was terrible so um but that's definitely the
plan has never changed and nor will it it's um
you know for me it's i i just you know understand
the the game and the risk associated with it and
i kind of just looked at my situation um and the
injuries that i've had and the the risk of injury
going forward and and that was simultaneously you
know that thought was happening as i was exploring
bitcoin on a deep level so then for me it was like
well how do i optimize if i'm trying to optimize
in every you know facet of my life like how do
i do it in compensation and especially given the
risk physically that my occupation demands and
that's where it was like man get paid in bitcoin
so for me if i'm you know when i'm playing i
want to get paid 100 of my salary in bitcoin
like that has never faltered it's actually
increased over time because it's funny
you know that gosh it's been a little over two
months at this point but i look at like just my
the increase in my education and understanding of
bitcoin now just compared in just two two months
time it's crazy how much more i know now what
do you feel like you've learned in two months
it's definitely so uh initially it was
definitely looking at like from a macro
perspective what was happening
fiscally and monetarily
and just the upside right the sound money
component and a big part of me wanting to do it
too was i was getting really just you know fed up
and frustrated with friends and peers saying well
i missed it right i missed bitcoin uh
yeah i need to go i need to go buy a doge
they told you to buy those oh no no they're saying
or something cheaper right anything that's cheaper
because that means better value right like it
makes it doesn't make sense like that thinking
so yeah if you think like that you probably just
haven't done the research right let's be honest so
were they telling you to buy like shiba
inu no no one tell me no one told me it
was telling me anything it was more
so just as i started to talk about
my um understanding of bitcoin and my passion
for it a lot of people like oh yeah for sure
for sure but i missed it man it's crazy i
missed it i'm too late like i gotta i gotta
go you know do some other altcoin that's
cheaper so for me i looked at it as
okay it makes the most sense to optimize for me in
my life my convictions at a level where i want to
get paid 100 my salary in bitcoin but then also
it was an opportunity to be like hey i'm a dca
bitcoin through 2022. it's not you're not late
like like long term we'll look back and see that
it was the right decision i understand there's
price action in the in the intermediate that's
going up and down and people see think
i'm a genius and then also an idiot right
i'm cool with that because i understand the long
term vision my time preface is extremely low and
so that was that was definitely um the
initial you know thinking and then lately
it's been the morality kind of in the
virtuous components of bitcoin right um
um sound money kind of things that we've
talked about earlier on in this episode just on
how it could be um you know hope for you know
other countries it's not just americans it's it's
everywhere it's billy conan's hope for everybody
and here's why and i just it felt it kind of just
um fell in line with my my principles and the way
my moral compass on just what i believe to be you
know providing to the world your energy your
economic contributions your resources and your
value to get paid in something that and it's okay
to save too like we shouldn't be punished to save
like if you look at history you know just from the
primitive ages like you know we we we developed
because we saved we stored food for when we didn't
know what would happen tomorrow and that is that
is um something to be protected right property
rights and so that's been like the latest kind
of deep dive for me and at the same time as
i'm going through that it was so cool to see
you know el salvador obviously and this following
the bitcoin convention with jack mullers and what
happened there and which is cool too because i
did a mission trip my senior year or my junior
year of high school to el salvador oh wow yeah
it was actually funny because somebody i think i
i have tweeted it was like you know just a
reminder you know el salvador chose bitcoin not
doge and people were like i swear you know these
bitcoin maxis don't know anything about salvador
and they're just using this opportunity they don't
know anything about it and i at the time i've been
i've been well yeah i i just went up from miami to
tampa to see my family and i was like hey jackass
so glad i was able to stop home uh put on like
my el salvador jersey that i got and this kind
of told him everything how i've been there and saw
the need for it and how people could benefit and
the people it was a funny moment yeah no that is
really cool yeah i mean everyone's gonna trash you
online no one's gonna love you um no people will
love you but they'll hate you as well um but yeah
so you make a really interesting point actually
about saving so this is my thing okay i feel like
we live in this um hyper consumer-centric society
where everybody is just buying and buying to get
their next you know kick of happiness that sort
of short time gratification and i feel like the
volatility encourages you to bloody well save
you know like i get paid on bitcoin as well
and i was getting paid at sixty thousand
dollars when bitcoin was literally at its peak
right so i've now lost fifty percent of my money
and people are like oh you're gonna sell no like
i have to save now like i have to save because i
because i obviously believe that it's going to go
back up i believe it's going to go to 500 000
eventually even probably 1 million in the next 15
years um i wholeheartedly believe that otherwise
i wouldn't dedicate my entire career to it sure
um so but it but it teaches you to save because
i can't sell that i can't sell that bitcoin
now otherwise i'm going to take a serious hit
yeah you can't you can't yeah you can't do that
it's um yeah yeah you're right like how could
you then it's it completely defeats the purpose
it's it's something that yeah is a long-term
play it's uh unfortunately yeah we live in a
consumption-driven economy and the the people
just want short-term gratification right and
um i see that in my industry right where i mean
guys are making life-changing money a game right
a game would be making what some people maybe get
in a lifetime can you give me an idea like what is
like an average i mean on average i mean i don't
know how to say that's a good question i don't
know what the average salary is i know i've been
league minimum all of my career i think people
sometimes link the nfl logo to this everyone's
a multi-millionaire that was something that was
unique about my story too was my conviction is
i'm not just this guy that's paid and i'm just
okay i'll do this you know yolo to the moon like
it was no this is something that aligns with
what i believe in um it was just a significant
part of my wealth but yeah i mean i would say
on average people probably make i don't know
probably a couple million a year because if you
look at the average the median maybe not but
like definitely the average is probably like
you know you can make 200k a game potentially
maybe like some guys are gonna make you know
25 million in a year as a quarterback
you know that's like a million a game
you have guys making probably three to
four what might be the average maybe
um but then the bulk of the league is league
minimum i think at least i think at least
forty percent of the league is um undrafted
free agents correct don't don't you know hold
me to that i wasn't quite um but yeah i think and
that's kind of what the more i thought like how
man as long as you're being smart with your
money and you can cover your short-term expenses
like the risk reward of the game and
what we're getting paid as league minimum
i thought wow the need for bitcoin is even
higher for those individuals like myself and
how long term you'll see wow i didn't just get
paid league and league minimum i got paid a lot
more like i know it's so easy to say looking
back you know oh if i would have bought right
five years ago how much money especially with the
growth that big wins had but i do think i think
i would have i think after taxes i think i ran the
numbers just using the average price over like the
the season the daily price um
i think it would have been like
seven million dollars more than just being
paid in fiat and and then you just keep going
down that and that's kind of what led me to my
point earlier where if you have a significant
you know significant amount of your wealth
and cash than the more need for bitcoin that
you need like i i couldn't imagine going through
2020 sitting in cash and i know so many athletes
that just whether they have advisors or this
themselves zetas hold cash they hold cash and
they put money in risky venture capital and
p e deals that typically don't pay out and
fixed income that's paying negative real yields
and have expenses that exceed their income and
then they stop playing and then they continue that
lifestyle and then that's why 78 of nfl players go
broke within three years really yeah i didn't know
that 78 percent did you say yeah roughly i won't
quote you again yeah i think you can honestly
quote me yeah it gets scared right because like
now i have a platform people just you know but
yeah that was definitely it was something that
it was a broke uh 30 for 30 um doc that's a
shame yeah it was talking about athletes and
just basically the what i just explained and i
would like to think you know since then we've
been aware of it and like to make better financial
decisions we're cutting expenses deploying capital
smartly but let's say you save as we all know in
this economic environment if you're saving cash
then it's you're destroying wealth right and
you're making the american dream that much
harder sure you're making a lot more money
but if you're looking at this preservation
of wealth it's all relative to your individual
circumstance right like there's so many better
ways to optimize in this holding fiat right now
because savers are getting punished like that is
very clear regardless if you believe in bitcoin
or not holding cash is trash like i think that's
starting to become more widespread which is also
another reason why i'm bullish on bitcoin adoption
as younger individuals are to speak becoming aware
of that and seeing okay this isn't you know the
best you know solution for me i need to invest
and i look at the properties of bitcoin versus
real estate fixed income and equities and i
still see bitcoin being the better outcome
yeah no i'm with you i mean i think no
i no but i'm with you i think you know
we live in a society whereby inflation is a real
problem and we're not really taught about it
and i think that's really unfortunate and i think
that you know the rich know that you need to
invest invest in the stock market invest in
property whatever it is and here's my thing
i just feel like um the average person doesn't
understand how on earth to do that and for once
we have something it's just and it's so easy and
it just you know you can create real wealth and
you know with inflation that we've seen over
the years i remember even like 10 years ago
having conversations about inflation and and
how my generation won't be able to get on the
property ladder and you know all this stuff that
your grandparents were and this whole conversation
and i just feel like we finally have something
like we have something to not make us feel so um
so screwed by the system um but that's really
interesting what you said about the players
um i actually had no idea that around 78 did
you say yeah that was the latest out that i saw
it could be um dated some um hopefully it's better
but yeah yeah i think it was like 78 and then
i think it's maybe 60 percent for nba athletes
because they make they make quite a bit more um
it is so but do you um given you're now super
in love with bitcoin i was gonna say bitcoin
maximalist because i haven't asked you about
that yet i don't know how you feel about the
rest of the space um but given you know you
found bitcoin and you're happy and everything
do you have plans to educate your teammates
other players have you tried um have you had
much backlash yeah no that's i mean that's
my passion uh yeah obviously i have a uh
a great opportunity with athletes because that's
where i have connections with that's where
yeah that's my friend group right
that's who i've operated with and
been an athlete you know professionally for
five years college since 2012 it's my life and
there's a huge need for it and but anybody like
my passion is making bitcoin simple for all people
to understand it but yes athletes for sure that's
definitely so i always you know as we said earlier
you know when i was studying thinking wall street
and then when i got in the league it was like okay
do i want to go work that type of life maybe
it's just you know i'm analytical but also
leveraging the personality and just being able to
communicate with people and maybe like you know
being a financial advisor for athletes and as i've
you know understood bitcoin more it's been okay
what's the need for how can i basically combine
all of it the intersection of professional sports
finance and bitcoin what is the overlap and
that's where one of the plans for me like this
your internet is cutting out yeah i'm not sure
if it's me i don't know if it's me if it's you
maybe you guys can let us know in the comments
if sean cut out for you a bit or whether it was
me did you see me okay like did i freeze yeah
no you you were fine okay oh you're back anyway
yay okay where did you lose me i kind of just i
kind of just got the whole this is your passion
you're going to help educate more people
um bring more people into sports and then
sorry bring more more of your more of your fellow
sports players into bitcoin and then i lost you
yeah yeah so basically just you know from
my history and what i kind of thought and
what i'm going to do now the overlap of football
or professional sports finance and bitcoin how
can i given my understanding and my knowledge and
passion for it help other athletes help people and
just explain to them the idea simply and provide
resources and just be an aid and preserving their
wealth like that's my passion and it's exciting
and yeah it's like a humanitarian mission
yeah yeah it really is it's like i definitely
want to just my next career whatever that is
like football obviously was um there's so many
opportunities to whether speaking engagements
or doing a camp and being a light for kids to you
know be a mentor and show like by example like you
know the dedication and sacrifice and work ethic
needed to be successful successful in sports but
you know beyond that it doesn't
necessarily check the box like
you know what i want to do next like whenever that
happens right it's like i want to do something
that isn't for money it is because i'm making an
impact positively on the world and eventually the
money will follow that based off the value that
i bring um wait so this is what i was going to
ask you though wait let me just jump in because
this whole conversation i've noticed you have a
mentality um which is i i need to have something
something after you know whether it's in case of
um physical injury so you've got your finance
degree um you know whatever it is you're always
thinking ahead which is super smart so once you
know say your body's tired no more no more nfl um
uh what what do you want what's the goal what
would you like to do because clearly you have
quite an entrepreneurial mindset you have
a humanitarian goal what do you want to do
yeah you're still you know you're you're like
you're like 28. yeah i'm 20 yeah 28 so i'm young
yeah yeah 28. um but yeah like we to what we said
like it wasn't it's not a plan b right because
it's playing plan a doesn't work if you have a
plan b but you can definitely it's an excellent
utilize you can utilize they're the same in my
eyes they've all they've always been the same
i've used football to get free education i've
used football to expand my network and have an
opportunity maybe to get opportunities on wall
street that maybe when it come to a person that
just you know didn't go to an ivy league school um
it's there's definitely been transferable skills
and be a professional athlete that apply to
any industry but yeah like i know if you look
at history anyone that thinks you're just going
to play forever and hopefully you play enough to
be financially set and then you can really just
work on the humanitarian component of it but that
doesn't happen for every athlete and you know
to our early point unfortunately even guys that
make millions of dollars they still are not set
because of the the lifestyle that they live so
what's the overlap it's it's again it's pr um
it's just allowing them to be financially free
and preserve their wealth and just be a resource
for them in education and provide the resources
to do that right and i think that the best
uh investment vehicle is through bitcoin
and yeah so my next endeavor yeah it's definitely
gonna be something surrounding bitcoin like i said
earlier it was always something that had to do
with you know wanting to be a financial advisor
but it's like i can still do
that and then now introduce
bitcoin within the exposure within the portfolio
because now at this point given everything that's
happening the infrastructure the politics get
involved the amount of money the upside just look
at what's happened if you don't have exposure it's
not you're not doing your fiduciary standard in my
opinion to your clients by not at least having
some percentage of your wealth allocated towards
bitcoin and it's all based off risk and current
expenses and what their just financial picture
their mosaic looks like would kind of dictate
how much exposure they have to bitcoin right and
i'm passionate about that and i know that there's
definitely something next and if it's you know
like you said i do have an entrepreneurial mindset
and if it's not that then it's falling in line
with a company that i will just go through oh
sorry i don't want to close right now but go
through a brick wall you know yeah yeah that
that leader that ceo that founder almost like
a players coach the coaches that i've had as
an athlete like i know the difference between
somebody that's a dictator that just doesn't
bring out the best in you or somebody that's like
man you check the box and everything that i would
want to do and you have some opportunity that
i can provide value to let's go do this and wake
up every single day with that mindset so yeah it's
it's i'm not you know that's probably that's
all the thought that's been towards it because
i'm a professional athlete all my most of my time
and resources go to being ready to play on sundays
but yeah whenever it does and that's next for me
for sure i'm excited about it too because it's
how could you not be i mean look at you you get to
do this every single day i'm sure you're ecstatic
every day right yeah i love it i mean for me it's
just it's just game changing um like i i have this
thing where i don't like to follow hierarchies
i don't like to follow i don't like to fall into
line um i'm very much um my own person and i
love what i do so much because it means that
i can do what i want on my own terms and bitcoin
has allowed that um at such a young age as well
you know um when if i compare where i'm at to
where some of my peers are at from school um
it you know it's it's worlds apart um and bitcoin
has allowed that this whole industry has allowed
that um i like i said earlier you know i think
like the climate right now is the geopolitical
climate is just absolutely nuts with all these
lockdowns and everything and you know bitcoin
for me is just like so i find so much comfort you
know and so much peace and the fact that like you
can really opt out of a system like there is
something you know and we've got cbdc's coming
um and i think they're gonna be awful they're
going to be terrible and they're going to have
a whole marketing campaign behind them and this is
this is i don't know it's it's really really cool
and i i say to my mum like all the time i say i'm
so blessed i'm so happy i'm so grateful to be at
the forefront of this revolution um because it's
it's in line with everything you know i believe in
yeah absolutely i'm blessed to say the same and be
kind of the earlier pioneers within the athletics
um spell you know the space and but also
there's so many good people that's what
i've realized too this in this time like even
leading up to miami but then after it's like
the amount of great people that i've met it's
so crazy like the smartest individuals and the
ones that want to do good for the world it
just seems inevitable that you eventually
spend time and go down the rabbit hole
yeah and just get it and once you see it
you can't unsee it right and it's been really
cool uh to experience that and i'm excited to
you know continue doing that yeah that's the thing
especially because you end up meeting so many
like-minded people and it's so refreshing because
you know your mentality can be of a certain way
and you don't understand why the people around
you don't see the world the way you do and then
you find this community and everybody is so
driven and sort of sees things the same way so
yeah it's it's it's truly amazing and i absolutely
love what you're doing i love that you've got this
plan you know after it's the humanitarian mission
you know i really respect it so i want to thank
you so much sean it's been such a pleasure um i've
honestly learned so much about you from you your
mission and i think i think it's so great before
we head off um do you have any last final words
uh no just you know thank you so much for having
me it's been awesome to tell my story and people
can find me at caulking22 on twitter and yeah
no it's just i'm blessed for the opportunity
and just do your own research that's what i tell
everybody that's what inspired me to make my
decision if i could just you know cause somebody
to sit down and spend an hour or two and not just
reading headlines and formulating opinions based
off that like really distinct for yourself um
that's it right and then match your conviction
you know with how much money you have in it
and just go from there totally
with you sean thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure thank you everyone
for watching and thank you to my sponsors
blockfy luna and compass mining we
will see you all next week bye bye